good morning Hank it's Tuesday so for
the last few months I had been working
out a few times a week with a trainer
named Sean and he has changed my life
considerably like I can now run six
miles in under an hour although all
things being equal I would still prefer
not to also not to brag I can now
benchpress 100 pounds 15 times in a row
which I believe according to the law of
transit of benching means that I can
benchpress 1500 pounds one time in a row
anyway I bring this up to explain why
I've been listening to the Drake song
started from the bottom now we hear a
lot recently it is an excellent song to
run to Hank I'm not sure you're familiar
with this song fortunately 90% of its
lyrics are in its title it's basically
about how drake started from the bottom
and then he and his crew are now at the
top meanwhile I have also been rereading
the autobiography of Benjamin Franklin
Benjamin Franklin was a founding father
of the United States and he invented the
lightning rod in five vocals and started
universities and fire departments and
libraries he was a very interesting guy
and then recently it occurred to me not
to sound like a compliment professor or
anything that Benjamin Franklin's
autobiography and Drake song started
from the bottom now we here are really
interesting and problematic to consider
together they would be first there are
the superficial connections they're both
successful people's narratives about
success like Benjamin Franklin
negotiated important treaties with the
French Drake says that there really
ain't much poppin off in the music
industry without him also both
narratives are just a smidge repetitive
like the titular course of the Drake
song appears like 35 times in three
minutes and Benjamin Franklin while he
was a very talented guy and everything
over uses a lot of words most notably
ingenious I mean if you can read
Benjamin Franklin thinks you're
ingenious but there are also much deeper
connections so the most famous moment of
Benjamin Franklin's autobiography is
when he is kicked out of his
apprenticeship in his hometown and the
whites out for the fair shores of
Philadelphia arriving with only one
copper shilling and a dream he spends
the copper shilling on three loaves of
bread two of which he gives to people
who are less fortunate than he and then
fortified only by that single loaf of
bread he builds a massive printing
Empire and becomes the founding father
of America Benjamin Franklin story is
the American dream of rugged individual
making his or her but usually his way to
the top via nothing but hard work and
ingenious audacity yeah except that
Benjamin Franklin didn't start from the
bottom he was from a family of wealthy
printers aside from that famous
hopper shilling he also took to
Philadelphia a letter of recommendation
from the governor of the colony and he
was the right class and the right gender
and the right race to become Benjamin
Franklin essentially the Benjamin
Franklin story has started in the upper
middle than I really got very near the
top but George Washington is still a
little bit above me I was close
similarly Drake did not actually start
from the bottom for one thing he is
Canadian which is arguably the best
place to be born in the world today also
his mom is a teacher and furthermore
from a very early age Drake had a
lucrative gig as a cast member on the
television program Degrassi Degrassi
Degrassi Sarah's here by the way
Internet the success narratives we hear
are almost always privileged narratives
and they almost never acknowledge that
privilege I mean none of this is to
denigrate the accomplishments of Drake
or Benjamin Franklin no other Degrassi
alums for instance are on the road
making half a million for a show and no
other person in the 18th century
invented bifocals despite many people
having Benjamin Franklin's privileges or
even more privileges but the underlying
idea of the self-made individual who
heroically on their own builds a
successful career in music or business
or writing or whatever is just deeply
flawed and as long as we believe it we
will collaborate too little and judge
others too often in the end echo I'm
probably a bigger fan of Benjamin
Franklin I appreciate Drake's retelling
of his own story more because while he
says started from the bottom which he
didn't he also says now my whole crew is
here
Drake acknowledges in a way Ben Franklin
never does that his success sprang from
and was fueled by a weed and that's
always the truth Hank I didn't develop
this astonishingly athletic body on my
own Drake didn't make his success on his
own even Ben Franklin relied on English
opticians to help him invent the bifocal
and speaking of how much I enjoy
collaboration Hank I'll see you on
Friday